hello um i don't have a routine
i feel i feel pressured now this might
be the most boring talk
i hope it's not but i at least don't
have a routine i also don't have any
entertaining
um gifts unfortunately
thank you um so thank you for the
introduction
um my name is catherine west my talk is
called
using rust for game development and
since you know probably a lot of you
here aren't game developers it's
what you can learn from it even if
you're not a game developer
uh so the genesis of this talk is that
you know on irc or discord i keep
getting these questions
um you know like how do you make a game
from scratch and rust
i've tried and maybe i run into you know
the bar checker complaining
or i try to make a game and i need
internal mutability
um or maybe it's just like they've tried
this
and they seem skeptical because they
think that the borrower checker is very
limiting um and i think that these are
all kind of
these three questions are kind of the
same this is like
beginner fighting the borrow checker
this is intermediate
fighting the borough checker and this is
advanced fighting the borough checker
um but uh you know obviously in case
it's not clear
because i'm here at russ conference at
russ comp talking about game development
i don't necessarily agree with these um
so
but the uh the trick is is that
you know you want to give an answer to
these kinds of questions these kinds of
questions
um and you know sometimes a small answer
is not appropriate for a question that's
about what happens when you grow
something beyond the small um
so this is my medium size
oops i've already messed up this is my
medium-sized answer
to this question um so before i go any
further
i'm going to have a lot of code in these
slides and i really
am sorry if people in the back can't see
all these slides will be available
online
but even better than that um i actually
didn't write this talk
for russ con bressconf i um i actually
wrote a long form blog post of this this
is way longer and probably way more
interesting
so i'm going to make that blog post
public at some point in the next week
so if you don't like my talk you maybe
will like my blog post
um and if you can't see then the blog
post will be there
um so uh i think
the real reason that i get a lot of
these questions is that
rust makes rust does make certain
patterns
more painful than others um this is a
great thing
this is probably my favorite feature of
rust is that it gives me this pressure
not to do the easy bad thing
um you know and and what i found is
is that these these things that rust
kind of guides me to do
are oftentimes the easiest generally
whether or not i was written in rust
and the reason i know this is because i
had to learn it the hard way
and i didn't have rus help
i'm going to talk a little bit about the
game i worked on a chucklefest called
starbound
i'm going to pick on myself a lot uh i
made a bunch of mistakes
and i'm going to talk about them they're
all my fault i can it's easy for me to
pick on myself
um and what i should have done like one
of the things i should have done is i
should have used something like ecs
design
and maybe if i'd used rust it would have
given me the right
guidance and pain to maybe pick these
better designs
faster so if you don't know what ecs is
uh don't worry because we're gonna build
one um
so the the this talk is gonna be
working through a game engine
from the simplest it can possibly
possibly be
to something that i think is appropriate
for like a mid-size project
and it's going to have an ecs in it um
and the reason that this works so well
with rust is that rust tends to reward
data-oriented design um and i might be
using this term a little bit different
than a lot of people use it a lot of you
know if you go look on the wikipedia
page for data oriented design
uh you'll see a lot of things about like
cash
locality and cash behavior and
performance and things like that but i
don't actually think that that's like
the most important part of it
and i think it has a lot more meaning
for a language like rust
and but i also think that these are kind
of two sides of the same coin
um but we'll get into that so
um what is a game what is a video game
it's
simplest possible form you make a game
state
uh so this is obviously very this would
be very complicated and large and
you know your entire game fits in this
one structure right
so players entities monsters whatever
goes in this one structure
and then you go into a loop so a video
game
uh you you you take input
right like from a controller um
you take input and then you run a bunch
of code
to update your game state based on the
input you you got
so if you're jumping you press the
spacebar or jump button
and your player starts jumping um then
you render what you got and you wait for
the next frame
repeat shoot
uh sorry okay i need to stop clicking
that
um so then you repeat uh
so what like this is the simplest
possible
game you want you can't even call it an
engine you make a game state you run a
bunch of code over it
repeat um so what can we learn from this
ultra simplistic example uh one
i don't recommend i don't necessarily
recommend you make a game this way
but you could make a game this way i
promise you can make a game this way
because i've seen them
i've seen the source code to unreleased
games that are written this way
with procedural ball of mud 12 000 line
world generation method i won't name
names but i've seen them
um and if you did it you'd have minimal
problems with the borrow checker
and a little bit of thought will tell
you why
every one of these procedures that you
run over your game gets complete
and total mutable access to the entire
game state
so if you have complete total mutable
access
you probably aren't going to run into
problems with the bar checker because
you've borrowed everything
um and you can one of the
one of the things the things that the
rest compiler will do for you is that
allow you to split borrows so if you
have a structure with a bunch of fields
you can borrow one field and then
immutably and then borrow another field
immediately and as long as it's a public
structure
rust understands how to deal with that
uh but it has some downsides
namely that everything is in one giant
morally global mutable mega state right
um everything is procedural you could
very end up
very easily end up with like a
procedural ball of mud where you don't
have your input system and this is
supposed to make the player jump
but i could just lean over here and just
mutate the physics state
because nothing is stopping you since
you have everything borrowed at once
so there are some downsides but it's
important to keep this in mind
because we're going to try and improve
this but we know this
could theoretically work and we're going
to improve on it
we're going to improve first we're going
to improve on it in the wrong way
um and we're going to do it with the
example of starbound because i did it
so we're going to try object-oriented
design in order to improve our
game engine so what are the principles
of object-oriented design
there's the single responsibility
principle uh
which says you know okay you should take
your data
and you should bundle your data up into
logical components
and then you should take the functions
that operate on those components and
call them methods
and bundle them together and it's called
a class
um encapsulation says that the data that
you bundle into a class
should be private by default or and you
should lean towards privacy
because you know somebody else might
mess with your data
um and it they might um you might have
to like
mess up in variance or uh and then that
you should lean towards
accessing that data through members um
the abstraction principle
says that it's rather than depending on
like having one class defined on another
you should lean towards uh depending on
some kind of abstract interface or
like you can see plus it would be like a
pure virtual interface
um and this is related to the last point
minimal coupling which says
uh that you you know if you
you shouldn't couple the design of one
class to the design of another
and instead interact through
these pure abstract interfaces uh
so let's try this let's see how it works
spoiler it doesn't really work that well
but we'll get there
um so this is kind of uh sorry if it's
hard to see back there
again all these slides will be available
um this is kind of like
the the smallest possible star-bound
game state so you have three entities
and if if you don't know when ncds
because we're using all this gamedev
jargon
um like uh if you have if you have a
world
um everything that's static it doesn't
move you can't interact with you can't
do anything with it but you can maybe
stand on it
that's you know your static data and
then anything you can interact with in
games is usually they're all entities
um so in this case our entities are the
player the thing you control
a monster which may be like a little
critter going around that you shouldn't
touch because it'll damage you
and then maybe some npcs that you can
talk to
um and then we have our game state
which is the you know the struck that we
made that's going to contain
the entire state of our game um one
thing to note here
is that our game state is like a list of
all the
the the non-entity data that i talked
about
and then this this this list of entities
and we've got this
if you don't know c plus i'm sorry but
hopefully it's not too distracting we
have the shared pointer to void
because we don't know what to put there
yet um
so you know we have entities as an npc a
monster and a player
so the type system is kind of in our way
so we have a shared point of
void um and we're going to improve this
in a sec
another thing to note from this example
is that one of our
internal states i have this i'm going to
use this a lot and this is going to end
up being important but there's this
entity index type um and this is
actually really interesting because this
is super common
in in c plus plus game engines in fact
i've never seen
a systems programming language kind of
game engine that doesn't have these
and you know this is this is a c plus
plus example so you might think like
okay well
this field is is player id so like you
know star runs a multiplayer game
you need to keep a list of all the
entities that are a player um
but you know why don't you use a pointer
you see plus plus you know the
we can live dangerously let's keep a
pointer um and the thing is
is that nobody does this because it's
wildly unsafe if you keep internal
pointers they will become invalidated
and your game will crash
so nobody in the systems game
development
environment like that all game engines
have this
it's either an id or some kind of index
or something
to identify entities and this is
important because we have to do this in
a lot of places in rust
but it's the best idea um and it has
other benefits like you know for network
serialization and filezilla it's hard to
see
as a pointer right um but you know this
is very common in all game engines
and this is kind of an important thing
so okay um
so we we had this sharepoint at a void
and it really sucks because we can't do
anything with shared pointer to void
so let's make this we're programming an
we're we're doing object-oriented design
right so let's make this interface
called entity
uh so let's very quickly think of all
the things that will be common to
every single entity position
i'm done i can't think of anything else
um
you know you might in our example all of
the the the player the monster and the
npc have all have velocity
they all have physics but maybe you have
a stationary entity
it turns out that uh yeah sorry
maybe there's a stationary entity it
turns out that there's not very much
in common almost at all so
you know starbound actually has an
entity interface like this
and it's filled with a bunch of methods
that all return like basically option
because some entities don't have them
and then
like you're kind of defeating the
purpose of having an entity interface
but
anyway uh so so but one thing we can do
is we can treat we can give them methods
so we're trying to do object-oriented
design
so let's say that every entity can
handle input state
so like a player might start a jump if
you hit space uh
and then every entity has to update
themselves uh
and they have to take in the rest of the
game state so like if you're a monster
and you're tracking a player you have to
know where the player is because
you so you and you have to maybe know
where other monsters are so you need the
rest of the game state
um and then they could render themselves
somehow we're not really going to talk
about that
uh so then the player you know
implements this interface the player has
a position they
handles input handles update handles
render monster and npc are exactly the
same
and now we can keep a shared pointer to
entity instead of a shared pointer to
void
uh okay this seems like it could work
um new requirements start coming in so
you make a video game you're constantly
going to be experimenting constantly can
have new requirements
uh monsters can track players because
they know the player's position
but they should track because it's a
multiplayer game they should check the
player that has the lowest health
all right well health is private to
player
because we're practicing encapsulation
so that's okay
we'll make an accessor not a big deal
uh more requirements start coming in
the monsters should not go after players
who are marked as admins
so starbucks is a multiplayer game we
have this concept of admin it's
not super important but um so okay we
can make more accessors
not a big deal aladdin is admin
no problem uh okay well we have to
continue on with development
so uh let's let's we need
monsters to start damaging players so if
a player gets too close to a monster
you know the you know it has some kind
of geometry around it if the player's
geometry overlaps with the monster
geometry
the player should be hurt well okay so
let's think about this
uh where do we put it
we're doing object-oriented programming
so we should take our
methods and apply it to the to the place
that it makes the most sense to go
so i guess the players damage themselves
but you could also say that monsters do
the damaging
they're the thing that does it there's
not actually a great place to put it
so we can pick one um we'll just pick
player players damage
themselves the player will check its own
bounding box with that of the monster
and will decrement itself in health if
we did it the other way then monsters
would have to ex
have access to players health which like
mutable access it doesn't seem right
either
so we'll do it this way um and we need
more accessories because you know now
the monster has this damage region and
the player has to check it
so one more accessor it's not a big deal
um so okay so you're making a stealth
game
and um if the player walks next to a
monster and they're on the ground
uh the monster might react in some way
that's no problem we'll add an on-ground
accessor to player
except we've been practicing good
object-oriented design and
our player has this sub-object right you
know we know that we shouldn't use
inheritance we've been told that a lot
you know inheritances by which you use
composition
so we've composed our entities with this
physics object um and only the physics
system
knows whether you're hit on the ground
not a problem
we'll add accessors to physics and we'll
add an accessor to player that just
passes on to the accessory to physics um
and as you can see that you kind of need
more and more of these and then
the more you do these these patterns
like composition
the more accessories you need how many
could you possibly need really
uh well um
this is the four real actual
starbound player class copied from the
starbound source code as of the latest
version
um you can tell that we've been
following good object-oriented
programming
and we've been using a whole bunch of
these for your virtual
uh interfaces because you know you
shouldn't you shouldn't have something
depend on the player necessarily you
might have something else that can
emote um so
uh you know we we i think there's eight
or nine of these
there's actually a little more like 35
of these interfaces
inside starbound um there's a bunch of
them so
let's let's just quickly go through all
the accessors in this class in this
so so
um yeah you gotta you gotta know how
much energy the player has you gotta
know how much breath they have
their protection whether they're forced
nude
that what kind of game did i make um
okay that that's that's for something i
know it's sports it's
it's for like the the player creator or
something like that
uh and if you're new you know you just
want to be nude
um just keeps going and going and going
oh shoot whether they're an admin or not
uh it was up there somewhere i don't
remember where it is
is admin yeah oh whether they're dead
that that sounds important
um oh okay
okay there's like 400 lines of these um
the this is lar
the number of methods to the player
class is like
200 lines longer than the number of
members in the player class
somehow i don't know um this one's great
because this is some like sub object for
for like uh the ship's ai and we just
gave up
and now like oh you can get it you know
immutably if it's an accessor
and also we need to mutate it and i'm
tired of writing i tired of writing
methods
so we just we just like there is
literally no difference between this
and just a public number um
so uh this is don't do that
don't make games that way but we're
gonna try this in rust
anyway and we're gonna see what we can
learn from it and what you're gonna find
is that this kind of design fails
quicker and there's a reason for this
okay so we start with the simplest
object-oriented sequels plus version
uh we have an entity interface uh and
you know we have our game state list of
entities
we're going to translate it to rust and
now we have an entity trait
and a list of entities um uh very
quickly this this
vector of option you know we have a box
entity because it's
it's a trait so we can't keep a direct
copy of it but also just just so you
know like this there's this option here
because
i'm keeping a vector of entities so you
know you might remove an sd and the
option becomes none
then you allocate a new entity you have
to go find a nun to put it in
um and then the rest originate so okay
right away this is already wrong this is
already broken
um so an incident has to update itself
right
it gets a mutable reference to self and
a mutable reference to game state
even if it got an immunitable reference
this would still be a problem because
an entity gets a mutable reference to
self and it's also
inside the game state all of our data in
the whole game is in this game state
that's mutable aliasing you can't do
that
so right away we try to make a method
and it doesn't work
so there's a bunch of ways you can solve
this and most of them are really bad
um you could do things like remove the
entity
and then call update and then put the
entity back um
it doesn't work uh the best thing you
can do which is bad
is to try interior mutability so
we have rough cell now all of our
methods take immutable references to
self
and this sucks if you try to do this you
go on rc
and you say i need why do i need this
rust sucks i need
i need rough cell you're fighting the
borrow checker
it's helpful but you know not
necessarily helpful if you've ever found
yourself in that situation this talk is
for you
um so it gets worse
uh say you know you you have this this
entity trait that's pretty sparse
um this is something that actually shows
up in starbound you have these like we
have like a tag system
everything is our found um we have this
tag system where you can you can get a
list like maybe in starbound it's like a
list of strings um you know this tag
method i've unalighted the lifetime so
it's clear
but this borrows the whole entity no
matter what
and returns a reference to tags so
you know already this is a problem
that's a lot of borrowing
um and maybe you know if you want to get
the ends uh get
the the tags from entity and then do
some operation that involves like
mutating the world
um you know maybe that's a problem and
it's even worse because if you need
internal mutability you can't return a
reference you have to return
a rough cell ref type right
this is really hard um
it gets worse the larger your game state
the more you borrow
so you know we have the game state uh in
starbound
it's like a 2d block based building game
right so you know
we have a method like this in our in our
version of this where you get a block
based on some like integral index and it
returns a block well
on a lighted this borrows the entire
game state
um this is a problem you you don't want
to have to call clone you don't want to
borrow that much
but the fact that everything is private
is getting in your way
and this is worse with traits so
i mentioned this because starbone has
this as well we have our world
class which has a million methods in it
um
and there's a world server and a world
client so if you're the server you talk
to a world server
constructor or client and they both
implement this this interface
and i tried to make i'm trying to
improve the performance of starbound
i've been doing a lot of perf work
um you know it i need the world's return
of reference
everything is terrifying in c plus bus
this is use after free
in rust you know it borrows absolutely
the entire game state and
you can't do anything and you're forced
to clone it so it's not very helpful
um so what are the takeaways for this
uh this is kind of common knowledge in
the games industry actually
but in case you haven't heard um
object-oriented programming kind of
hurts more than it helps
um and this is kind of insidious because
in a game you have these objects and it
calls out to you right
what's an object well player that's like
a physical object
monster block right and these sounds
superficially
superficially appealing but if you keep
going it's actually
quite harmful most of your concerns end
up being cross-cutting concerns
things like damage or collision right
multiple entities collide with each
other
it doesn't make sense to have a collide
method um
and these this bad design that we talked
about
fails quickly in rust you start getting
pain points it starts it's like the rest
compiler is telling you that maybe this
is not a good idea
and one of the takeaways is that i
find it helpful to force myself
to think about things as just data like
to think
in a data oriented fashion and by that i
mean just
like just concentrate on the
representation of my game state
and don't conflate the methods that
operate on the data
with the representation of the game
state or this date of whatever you're
doing
okay so this is a bust in rust
uh let's go back to the beginning um
so this is kind of a rust version of our
first uh our first data model for
starbound
uh you have a player entity you have a
monster entity you have an npc entity
they all have some physics um
uh so like we're not going to do the
shared pointer to an interface thing
we're not going to do
box entity uh let's instead use an enum
so this is all the kinds of entities we
have
and then in our game state we just keep
a vector of
these entities which are either player
monster and pc
uh then we have this this basic update
structure that we had before um
so cards on the table
this is fine if you're making a game jam
game
probably stop here you know if if you
want to use an ecs that's fine but
this is not so bad like especially for
small things right
like yeah your entire game seat is is
available to everything but
it's actually fine so i wanted to
mention this because
i'm going to explain a couple of steps
beyond this and each one of them might
be a stopping point
if you wanted to make a game engine from
scratch uh
so so one thing i wanted to point out
though is that see this physics system
so the physics system needs to go
through every entity that has a physics
uh member so but here this is
there's this enum here so all entities
have physics or maybe even most entities
have physics we add more entity types
um so but it needs to under the physics
system needs to understand every single
entity type
it needs to match on the enum and then
see you know it needs to know which of
them do have
a physics cipher it won't compile and
you have this like
it's it's less it's it's not that easy
to
to like deal with a subset of entities
that have the same state
we can fix this though uh we can
unify our entity type so instead of
having an entity be an enum
we can take every member state that an
entity has
and we'll just shove them all in one big
structure so
uh you know most entities will have
physics
but um you know this isn't you know
option physics and then entities might
have health
uh and then we have all these these like
player monster npc
um like types that that were that were
there before but we were just like
if if you're a player you you have the
set if you ever monstrate with this set
uh so um this is this is useful
um but what's even more useful is if you
generalize this a bit so before um you
know a monster
had a current target right uh like in
this in this
uh slide you know a monster can be
aggressive towards a current towards
some kind of player
well here we take this out and we make
it its own
little state so we've just
kind of generalized our fields a little
bit and sometimes you can't do that
because you know we still have
stuff that only makes sense for a player
but but this is kind of interesting to
think about because
it's a give and take but this allows you
to express
more states than the previous one in
this you can express
a an aggressive npc and maybe that's
good
maybe you would you would want that but
you can also
express a an aggressive player
by setting the the the player to
the play setting that this field and
then also setting the aggression field
and maybe your engine just doesn't know
how to handle that maybe that doesn't
make any sense maybe aggression only
makes sense
like if you have an ai system and the
player's not run by ai so it's important
to remember that this is this is
powerful
and you can do this but it's a give and
take
so you can go further and
this is usually the part where if you're
reading an
explanation of what an ecs system is
they focus on
because they they look at this as in
purely from the lens of performance so
this is kind of confusing so let's go
back
you know we have this entity structure
with all these optional fields
and we have this vector of of these
entity structure
we're taking it and we're saying that
instead of having a vector of of structs
we're just going to have all of the
vectors for each of those parts
in one top level structure this is kind
of called the array of structs to
structure arrays
transform if you're if you're into data
oriented programming
and we're going to do this transform and
we're going to do one more thing where
we give
all these parts a more informative name
we're going to call them what they are
which is components
so if you've been paying attention we
now have entities and components
and our systems are just these
procedures that operate on a game state
so so we're getting we're getting close
right
um so uh
let's see what are the takeaways so far
thinking about
the structure of your state is really
powerful
and not thinking necessarily always
about
the methods you've decided to apply to
that state
um another takeaway is that you can do a
lot
with vects and indexes into x um the
reason i mentioned this
is because i see this a lot actually not
just in game programming
um but but uh you know you
you need like to make a graph structure
or something and you need to update it
and you go online and people give you
advice about like using arena allocators
or like rc and internal immutability and
those are great
those tools have their place but
seriously seriously seriously
just put your nodes in a vac and use
indexes it is so easy
that should be the first tool you reach
for um
however it still has some problems um so
if you do that and i do that um
when you get an index to something in in
your your vac of of
members or your vac of nodes or whatever
if it's a graph
um and you delete one um that index is
still valid
and if if you think about this this is
kind of like
use after free like if you can think of
your indexes as
kind of like pseudo pointers um if you
if you free a node like if we freed an
entity
and then use an entity index to get that
you know to get that entity we
hopefully we would notice that it was
gone but if we allocated an entity right
afterwards
then you know we might not notice that
it's gone we might get a random
this other entity and that that's it's
safe but it's
not great we can solve it
um so this is a pattern that is super
common in the game dev community and i
don't think
enough rust stations know about so i
included it in my talk
we're going to talk about generational
indexes and a generational index
is just this index we were talking about
like entity index with one extra field
it's called a generation so if we had an
allocator for such a thing uh we might
allocate
a generational index and it would give
back like a zero with a generation of
zero
allocate another one it gives back one
with a generation of zero
allocate and uh deallocate the zeroth
index
allocate another one we get back an
index of zero so still
all of our indexes are small and we can
store them in a vec
but we never repeat our invariant here
is that our generational index allocator
will never return
an index that is ever equal to a
previous one i mean unless
unless you make this generation overflow
64 billions
but if you if you can do that your game
technology probably has cloud in the
name
so you probably have bigger problems um
but these are these are useful because
they solve this
um this use after free problem of
indexing
um and to go a little bit further we
just need one more thing which is this
generational index array which is just
like an associative array of these
indexes so instead of a vec it's just
like an easier version to deal with the
vacuum option of t um you know you can
set
and you can set values based on
generational index and if you get them
out
crucially um if the generation
must be up to date so if you have an
older generation you get back undone
um so putting it all together
uh instead of having these vec of
options we're going to have
uh this entity map which is just a type
def of this generational index array
and then we're going to rename entity
index to entity because it's no longer
we don't have to worry about it anymore
there is no such thing as an entity
anymore
so entity index entity id we're going to
call this index
entity and we're going to keep all these
entity maps of all of our components
this is an ecs system
uh takeaways generational indexes are
awesome if you don't know about them
uh they solve a whole lot of the
problems of regular indexing for doing
this internal mutability
there's a crate for it it's called slot
map
and i couldn't use it in the talk even
though i really really wanted to because
it's missing a key
feature you can't in slot map allocate
these indexes separately from using them
you have to bundle them all up and it
gives you kind of a structure but you
can't
allocate the indexes separately um if
you're the author of the swap map crate
and you're at ross comp
i am super sorry for calling you out on
stage um
uh but you know uh i have a i have
another
version of this uh i'll i can release
that as a that sounds like a threat if
you don't make this change i'm gonna
release a competing version
i didn't mean to sound like a threat um
so so okay one more one more uh
transformation set of transformations
and we're we're done so
dynamic typing everybody loves dynamic
typing
um you know it's great in very tiny
quantities
um but first we need uh a type
we need this structure called any map
which is great because there's a crate
for it
and it's not missing any features and i
don't have to call anybody out on stage
um so an any map very briefly is is
a map like it's like a set of types
where you can store exactly one of any
type so
you can put a t in and then if you put a
t in before
you can get it back out it's just that
simple
um so this is where we were before
and we can see like you know every time
we add a component this list is going to
grow
and what actually will end up happening
is we we we're going to list all of our
types a whole lot
and we're going to find a pattern to get
to deal with that but but just in this
one one instance all of these uh
components like
adding to this list can get tedious and
and
every time we add we are potentially um
you know touching we're touching a
dependency of every single system that
we have
so let's keep them in any map
um so you know the type system stops
being helpful when you use dynamic
typing
so um you know we're going to have these
entity components but they're just
the these collect these collection of
any sorry
entity maps um of type t
uh and let's go even further and we'll
keep all of our non-entity data in any
map as well
and we'll call those uh resources and
we'll change our name
from gamestate to something more
informative we'll just call it what it
is
which is an ecs system
we have these any maps the type system
stops being helpful so
you know you might have an interface
like this so you can get our component
out
based on some type t uh you can get a
resource out based on some type t
um and we've added this com these
component and resource traits
which i'll talk about in a second um but
this this is an ecs system
uh so um
you might balk at this like sudden
introduction of dynamic typing
and you would have a point kind of um
this is not
vastly better than what came before
until we add one more pattern
um and i don't this is common like
outside of rust but i actually don't
know what to call it inside rust so i'm
just going to call it the registry
pattern
so we're going to make a registry for
all of our components
so we're going to have this this
structure called a component registry
and we're going to call register
component for every single
component that we have in our whole game
uh we're gonna do the same for resources
and you know this we have to keep a
bunch of stuff in here like
like you know box functions and it gets
kind of gnarly but if if your component
has me if this component trait has
methods on it that allow you to like
load from a file what you end up being
able to do is you end up
being able to have these methods on your
registry that says hey
go take an ecs and put every component
that we know about in our game in the
acs
and then you can also do this where this
like load entity say your component
trait knows how to load from a json blob
uh you can say hey go load an entity
into my ecs based on this config file
um so this this might be like some kind
of array of all of the components
and then it gives back the entity after
adding them all and you can do the same
exact thing for resources
where you uh you know you set up all
your resources and then you can load any
given resource
um so then because everybody loves
globals
uh we can take all of our registries and
put them in a big top level registry
this is i i'm joking but this is
actually fine because
i mean this is this is kind of like
enterprisey um but
uh you know you might have seen
something like this even in like java
where you have like a list of all your
types
but this is actually super useful to be
able to say at any at any moment like
you have this global registry
that knows about all the types in your
game um and then
you can have these these these functions
here like load component registry
and and load resource registry you can
put those
in like if you have a component slash
lib.rs that lists all your components
put the component registry right below
it and you can list all your components
right
so uh by so this is a super useful
pattern
um so what are the takeaways here uh
dynamic typing is powerful and useful
but obviously you need to be careful
when you use it
but if you can use it in just the right
place
you'll notice that this has kind of
solved the last problem that we had with
our
super simple game design right so you
have you declare all these systems right
and they
they you know we had this problem where
every time we added something to
our ecs state um we would immediately
uh be messing with the dependencies of
every single system
but now a system can only know about a
part of our game state if they know
about that type
so you can just look at the import list
for any given system and see whether it
depends on something
and it breaks up this everything is
depending on everything else
not if you need to dynamic typing like
this usually you'll have something
like a type registry to go along with it
um
this pattern is super common in
object-oriented programming you might
call this a component factory but if i
think if i said i component and
component factory
i would rightfully be left at um
but oftentimes these patterns in
object-oriented programming are really
complex
and any map kind of simplifies this you
know if if
if you're going to have dynamic typing
and downcast just kind of own it
and just put everything in any map
and any map is awesome uh so
uh like let's just wrap up here really
fast let's see what time it is i'm a
little over
uh you know i didn't talk much about the
performance implication
implications of things like ecs systems
and i kind of did some purpose
because i've read a lot of really
confusing ecs explanations
and i think that they'll they can kind
of lose the larger point
which is that like it's it's very useful
and powerful
to just stop thinking about objects
sometimes
um uh i also think that you know
you you have things like data oriented
programming which are
classically just thought about just for
the reasons of performance
that that this is actually kind of more
important for rust
because rust has this focus on like
ownership and borrowing and then the the
data oriented design
can can both make for better performance
and also for easier an easier time with
the borrow checker
and critically these are kind of two
sides of the same coin
um uh i apologize if
you've heard a lot of this before i feel
like i'm kind of retreading old ground
like especially in the gamedev community
if you if you hang out there are
interested
you know a lot of these things are kind
of considered common knowledge like ecs
design
and object the fact that object-oriented
programming is overrated
if you have heard them i hope that this
is maybe a simpler explanation that
you've gotten in the past
um and i hope you've if you know
if at the very least found some good
design ideas or some good features that
you may not have known about uh or may
not have thought about otherwise
um and also just to finish up there's a
lot i didn't talk about
i didn't talk about all the great crates
if you actually want to make a game in
rust you know you know don't write your
own ecs system go use specs
right specs will do all this and it'll
schedule your your systems and it'll
have great performance and you know
don't make your own ecs system i just
wanted to explain it um
but also there's other ways to make
games you don't have to use an ecs
system you can use the actor model
there's lots of great ways to make games
i was not able to talk about all of them
and that's it
thank you very much